you want to have a piece of that might
just be stole us no I'm gonna give you a
little piece I like it so much that I'm
not giving it I'm like I'm like
harboring settles it settles in the
mouth isn't it it settles right down in
the middle of the mouth it's like
drinking hot cocoa it settles right down
the middle of your mouth that's a nice
chocolate right coffee place called -
guns - guns best coffee in the world -
guns no well - guns Hatton Beach I
caught us be stars yeah change your name
though you know but change your name I'm
sorry it's Clint Eastwood the owner
change your name
well all right Val Kilmer huckleberry
change your name it's Shh
but I've caused me more that plays more
on offense but more no please I'm asking
you if you could just be a little bit
kinder and morons
dude you brought some [ __ ] fruit
daddy brought fruit well daddy brought
fruit from the market I brought some
dude like come in with all these treats
I just felt like it today you brought
some berries berries yes Harry
well well I don't know let's bring him
up and see what he looks like
here's the thing he grows the
strawberries according to the season so
they're as natural as it gets because
remember fruit used to be seasonal right
and then season on then you ate a
shitload of and then you didn't need
food during the rest of the year Oh
Oxnard here's Barry so not far no come
for a walk snart hurry Iwo moto makes
sense he's Japanese a couple things you
[ __ ] don't understand one of the
things you know is there's an art in
Japan where they grow the sweetest
melons the sweetest berries and
literally they'll clip all the other
berries
way so they'll sell one cantaloupe in
Japan for $5,000 well I hate that when
you weigh over yes then eight five
million dollars buck net no man that's
why I did it but it'll be 40 50 bucks
for a cantaloupe
that's a they give it to you as a gift
that's it yeah but it's an artisan count
yeah so you brought these little tiny
babies and what you don't realize is
when you when they're organic and
they're from Harry's yeah himself yeah
they're tiny little things I told you I
told you and everybody in this room I
like my berries like I like my tits big
and a fake like I want them in my mouth
I like him fake you want to bite into a
red berry and have it have a white
interior yeah and just bust in my mouth
and basically basically sour take me to
flavortown
you want to sour your flower back your
friend they watch fights with with his
died here take me flavortown yeah
[ __ ] take me take your berries take
me to flavortown I like myself a little
sweet I want when I'm buying my bit my
strawberry I want it read all the way
through yeah that's how that's how God
intended it nature's candy it's nature's
candy and to that real candy because I'm
an American and I believe in God are you
doing you cuz you're you're a [ __ ]
you're from another country and we know
this nope I believe in God - I just want
my god a little Botox as he gets older
yeah I understand you like you're not
afraid of technology there's details I
said to my friend I got it's real and he
goes if you can touch them they're real
difficult on the real baby yeah and so
that's why they made them that's right
either way my hair berries we have some
I got some chocolate chip cookie and my
tummy berries in my tummy those nice
you're fresh off the plane from San
Francisco I came back from doing cobs
for the make-a-wish Foundation some
videos from from our boys Yosef and
Tariq yep now but now Poppy's card got
declined up there you're trying to buy
the boy some ice cream the card got
declined that's all I got a video very
nursing Park and they say can you please
pay dried more money because his car got
declines they're pieces of [ __ ] they're
liars and I hate nope and then I saw you
also a whole new camera taking a picture
for Jake Shields and nobody recognized
you and you kept yelling out cold Birds
and everyone went what that's right
so Jake they said is here - Jake which
Noord me and not me but then they
finally go you're a comic - nope and I
said you there that yeah it was
interesting
I worked out with how to work out with
dion jordan number three draft pick in
the NFL Oh years ago years ago years ago
he's 30 now he's 6-7 to 60 I'm playing
for the dolphin playing not for the
Dolphins he's playing for the he was
playing for the Raiders his troubles he
hawks yeah okay
and he's right man we did we did some
foot drills yeah we did some push-ups
stuff like that and please alright time
yeah
tark was that no I take my workouts no
Lee so you worked out John Jordan you
mean you watched him and then like a
toddler tried to keep up don't like the
way you're talking that's what's going
on we're talking right now they also
sent me video of you work it out it was
body it was body exercises and he and I
he was like this he goes he goes like
this is I was working out he goes dude
feed it quick and I go yeah thanks and
do some sports he goes you do a lot of
sport then they say can you catch a ball
cuz let's jump Seattle let's jump to
Seattle and you play for the Fiats yeah
he said let me tackle you him let me
come here around the outside uh-huh and
got some speed not happening now I
didn't really dude your boy last night
at the comic store ridiculous night the
lineup was so [ __ ] stupid Lee
ridiculous I'm getting ready to leave
right Rogan pulls in he said don't go
anywhere I was getting in my car microts
up yeah he gets that and this is
hashtagged all homo he gets out of his
car he's by that carnivore diet
he had a a [ __ ] spelt spelt trimmed
black shirt on
yeah bad carnivore diet and he just had
a look at the Harris Sam Harris see I'm
here now you a smart guy and he gets a
scar it was Tom Cruise I was a Utah Cruz
he looked unbelievable
I went hold on I might or dude you look
unbelievable in every gay way possible
yeah you look unbelievable right now and
what are you doing it was just carnivora
think well I get in carnival now I'm
going Carver because he's that's rude
I'm sure I've never seen him like this
unbeliev I was like what the [ __ ] are
you doing dude he was Carter I feel
great and a lot of people talk [ __ ] i
hears I feel great man I've never seen
him look better his skin was going to
eat yet there's a skin looks he had this
this this trimmed [ __ ] black
button-up shirt that was that was Tay
alert Wow I think this is the best
you've ever lived dude
well maybe Brian should I'm not eating
any more [ __ ] sugar I'm only eating
better I needs a little kick in the ass
but I got I got to go the gross Store
and lining it up otherwise I'll just
start to that what today's last day
start a little salad
nope I'm not doing it you don't need to
do it you look good you know what's
going rogue and look and then Jeselnik
he comes out of your dude you've lost a
ton of weight he owes
stop drinking stop eating sugar stop
being carbs dude down 20 pounds what the
[ __ ] is going on tighten when he cometh
looks like a [ __ ] supermodel but
everybody's tightening us happening I'm
the shittiest looking one here
well we're tightening up a little bit
tighten up people a little older than
you are too so what happens is they go I
got to start tightening up I know right
oh yeah start now though I'm not
arresting look better all the years I've
known as a holy [ __ ] it's really sad
sorry I said the other day I go your
skin looks very glowy and smooth again
in every gay way possible is it did you
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah I don't know
yeah it was insane it's so distracting
and then so check out the lineup be
right Sam goes on then I go then
Whitney Joey Diaz Dave Attell and then
Chris D'Elia yeah that's a hotel just
jumps on thanks again
I mean this guy in the world oh my but
the funniest guy in the world I think so
yeah he had nothing so so hard in the
back just so hard every hobo
get his bag like good treats you know
you're back in the green room I want
Bobby Lee
outside but you were after me and went
Bobby Whitney Joey a tell me Chris talk
about getting your money's worth
oh yeah so tells back then he doesn't
really know everybody's they kind of
talking to Whitney telling everybody is
this bag of treats and he goes I'm going
on soon uh you're not like pink room
he's was I'm just I'm just gonna put
this back here they see him look at me
and that that Craig guy is there and
just some other you know like saying
guys they just oh just anybody here
so funny his stand-up is I mean I've
I've never seen anything like it
he's like I've and and it can be he's go
yeah you see him he's the comics comic
when he does ten of all of us we all
left the green all the comics left the
green went to the side I've I've always
seem to have the monster try something
store yeah I every comic stop what
they're doing walked out and watched the
town now destroy but I thought of you
last night you appreciate this because I
remember a long time ago you and I were
doing we did like Howard Stern's wrap up
show and we're doing that with those
guys and I didn't say much and Bryan
just took over did his thing
we got das I didn't say [ __ ] anything
and you're like dude you don't have to
say anything sometimes less is more
yes I was on and you just were you
bouncing off me you don't have to be the
center like you don't have to be
sometimes just goes further to be quiet
so last night we're all like hanging out
it tells doing his thing Whitney it's
Bobby Dilley wrote everyone's in the
circle and I didn't say anything
I tell Jojo you're quiet huh how's a guy
I'm soaking up man
I wonder bill I have nothing to offer
you guys I'm just soaking it sure I'm
shouldn't be talking no I just want to
soak this that's great to do that I
thought anything wrong with I said I'm
soaking up man I'm soaking sometimes
that's so micro print yeah it's a great
that's a great lineup right there yeah
man I think that's very appropriate and
you can learn so much a tell you got to
remember the first time I saw tell the I
think Time magazine said here are the
group of young people shaping our golf
culture oh well and Dave Attell was
featured one of the features in that
newer young young comedians this was
1992-93
uh and he and patty Jenkins and I when
we went and watched because she said I
want you to start doing Stan
so we went to a comedy club and I she
told me to do it she's the reason I do
stand-up and I went and watched Dave
Attell that's right so it's confusing I
went to watch Dave Attell greg Giraldo
Patrice O'Neal she's louis c.k police
went back this is what this was the one
is just getting going but they were all
moms
then and Dave Attell was as funny then
as he is today and I'm not exaggerating
I was so astonished burst bub that whole
line of cuz they were all killing me and
I was gonna get into stand-up and I was
the funny guy in my group and I went
patty said stop biting your nails she
said stop biting your nails I was
fighting my nails cuz I was so
overwhelmed
I couldn't even laugh you know when
you're that overwhelmed you can't laugh
you're you're just so your sewin all
taking it in
you're just an awful lot it's it's a
form of power where you just can't stop
looking at them and you're like how do
you how does a human being do that how
do i I could never come close to that
it's just overwhelming this is too much
and it's what happened I I just couldn't
speak and I was only I had my body when
asked I was so anxious and so
overwhelmed with I guess ocean really
yes yes the beauty the beauty of human
beings when they're at their best and
comedy when it's done like that and when
you see a lineup like that in 1993 and
remember there wasn't a way to really
make money you had to do clubs I don't
even think there was very little touring
there was never clubs but it wasn't
nearly like it was Vegas that you were a
New York guy yeah you did comedy in
clubs and made where you could I just
stayed quiet cuz you know tell literally
is it goat and so he was talking just
the nuances in like the details he was
talking about someone asked him out
shooting a special inside the main room
and he was going through like what how
many seats you take out for the cameras
here and the shot over here and you're
just like yeah this why weren't you in
the o.r and just you're like holy yeah
you're talking about it guys I didn't
say a word
yeah 30 you did say word 30 years in
didn't say a word yeah and been crushing
rooms for 30 years like I mean but even
that's still what was cool as he went
back then he sees Sammy and Sam cuz you
didn't go on after Joey or Whitney or
Bobby he's like whatever you want man
and he was kind of crowd is it though
you know just like every comment right
what kind of crowd is it I thought it'd
be a deer anytime I need like okay well
I feel like I'm gonna field out and he's
I depend on the comments to depending
what I do so he goes out there and get
you tell you just yeah well what's funny
about mastery in your life is that there
are different schools of thought like
one is the idea that well I can do a
bunch of things well and
there's another school thought which is
I'm gonna do one thing really well and
if I really get good at that I'll figure
out the rest let's guys that's when he
land and life isn't as much a mystery
because you're gonna it's gonna require
all of you and it's gonna require you to
take into account so many things like
when Michael Jordan was speaking about
Kobe yeah Kobe would call him three in
the morning and asking about different
post how to post up and process and and
asking Michael Jordan a question I
Michael's a [ __ ] dumb questions but he
wanted to know the details the minutiae
and there's something that's that that's
very very beautiful contest and now you
saying that I wish you'd wipe the cookie
off your shirt nuts about the details
yeah yeah let's continue details but now
some details get to your point you
remember when I told that sir how mark
muñoz asked me to speak to those guys
cuz they weren't showing up to pack yeah
so home I'm Toni go home
I know kids who are obsessed with this
they're calling me at 3:00 and more in
the claw mark that's the best advice you
could've given us go home
wait don't waste your time here same
thing with comedy there's there's some
these guys we know who they are and you
know it's I know young guys like like
Chappell lacy or you're open or the
Chappell AC dude I'm talking doing three
four sets at night he's audition for
Netflix show he's hustling dude yes I
know that guy
yeah and then there's other guys that we
know like I might do a set this week I'm
like oh what's that Papa you're
competing with these guys over here man
so they give a kid who emceed for me at
the make-a-wish uh I was listening to
him that was his dream that was his wish
he wanted he wanted nobody want to get
in stand-up but i I've listened to him
and I realized he wasn't working he
wasn't right he wasn't performing a lot
I could tell been doing this too long
well you came upstairs and he knew and
he said what do you think you get a
chance to hear my set and I said yeah he
said he just looked at me goes I should
write more huh I go what do you think I
just let him says yeah I wanted to feel
bad a little bit because the only way
he's gonna change if he feels like [ __ ]
you slap another good faith I didn't say
anything did you slap him like III said
words you just take out a bank
I'm gonna slap a slightly stoopid
[ __ ] face lie don't you remember this
moment you don't get to be on stage with
me because there are too many great
people over who work really hard who get
to be on stage so you don't get to do
that you don't get to do that and so I
wanted him to feel bad because he should
feel bad and and if he wants this then
he's got to get it if he doesn't get out
of here it's okay but it's not for you
you want to be you want to be you know
to dilettantes a dilettante to somebody
who dabbles in and what they do they do
it it goes back the same things less
similar is defined like here in Pico is
talking that you say how he's obsessed
and I have to tell him dude go somewhere
get out of the gym and he goes I'm
obsessed with it
what do you think that comes from he
goes when I was 10 I went to Dagestan
for wrestling and I wrestled with the
other kids who were 10 years old
and saw even younger than that and older
than that and the regiment and the
discipline and how obsessed they were
with it so that's why I trained so hard
man every day I'm thinking of them every
day I wake up I'm thinking those kids in
Dagestan it's all they care about don't
care about you so it's as no social
media they don't care about in every the
years any look city is their training
every single day to beat me and my
friend my friend she's crying son is
wrestling a nicer by Jean right next to
that extent same exact thing towards
that and he said his son is he said you
have no idea how they train and he his
time started when he was eleven now
son's 13 he came back to California and
just [ __ ] your Pecos I don't know it's
life dude it's all they cared but same
thing was staying up like it's like that
young kid Brett Forte in Canada he's
doing a thousand sets a week meant a
million [ __ ] sense he's obsessed with
it yeah I think you have court shows he
opened for me when I was in Calgary I
had a brand new brand new 45 man I
forget when that was I was last summer
has a brand new 45 all-new shoe I've
never seen yeah destroy because it's a
mine the night before you know what he
did he wasn't playing on it open for Jay
Pharoah how do you make that happen
hit up Jay that hey let me Ken the hotel
let me spit let me let me give you some
my stamp right here like here and now
that he's so so when I when I saw what
they were gonna give the the other woman
so Maalik my my openers a monster he
come with you to kill the Tartars like
to cob yes Tariq sent me goes here he
goes
lewd star so special I love him he's
just [ __ ] amazing but nobody works
hard to say my same idea he's so hungry
all he does is right we might think we
sheen and prays that I'm Greg I agree
the woman but the one that's like chin B
and [ __ ] at audio put in video podcast
yeah I know I don't tell Jim do great
job did you I expect you to do that the
girl Julie ash who came on she's just a
locals stand-up comic but III said you
cannot gonna do 15 you got into 12 you
know cuz I hear a woman no it's because
I chose already going long and you're a
woman yeah and there was a guy who a
female well make-a-wish had the gun at
the auction first the guy has never done
it so what they did is they had a guy
dressed up like a [ __ ] dinosaur the
guy had a dinosaur suit and he was a
t-rex though it's t-rex alright he
wasn't saying anything he was doing this
on the side and the other guy was saying
can we get $50 anybody well the t-rex
what were they raising the money for
dinosaur make a wishes for children sick
children and they have one wish before
they you know and what was someone's
wish well we raised $40,000 so that we
can make someone's wish happen gotcha so
I'll always do that stuff but I said let
me do the auction next year never let
his mom you've done it before let me do
stand-up and then after that they're all
on a high and then I will raise the
right [ __ ] money don't do it this way
with this poor guy who's never done it
and you have a dinosaur left t-rex
dumbass yeah but you know the t-rex
you're handing out sandwiches dressed
like a t-rex oh yeah yeah that's what
that's what it was I'm 40 year old man
the gal the gal who said I said just do
12 that I could see her face fell
because she wanted to 15 3 minutes means
a lot to somebody who's doing it givers
I watched her I watched her and she was
killing and I went I said don't let her
give her the 15 because she was too good
and she deserved it yeah [ __ ] I know
it sounds like a little thing three
minutes it's it oh but it's everything
he misses it yeah it's a lot because
you've never gives a specialty but
here's the thing it's a ton especially
you're killing your playing on 15 the
other thing is three minutes is eternity
if you don't have if that's can you only
have 12 that's what I was always last
three there forever yeah
will ruin your staff forever for effort
yes that that's crazy anymore right
about that and people don't realize that
three minutes sounds like whatever but
you could it's you couldn't have
described it better again it's back to
fighting it's like when I speaking
fighting Gabri good luck in the third
round exhausted my coach is out four
minutes laughs oh my god
if I could I make time out Hey mmm oh my
god tell me half way dude formats is
such an eternity Oh would its forever
bright switch when you're so tired you
have this Oh Brazilian man but your
wrestling is a full round when you're in
high school four minutes left
oh my god well Stillman rod do you get
[ __ ] me dude oh my so tired that's so
long dude four minutes four minutes I
will never forget that as long as I live
4-minute can't imagine there's a few
things I'll never forget - I forget who
was I fighting I forget who I was
fighting I've I've been Lavar Johnson I
forget I was coming off a loss and my
coach we like we I went away from home
Oh to Jackson I came back sir it's tied
together in Loren Landau who's been with
me from the start
who's my train at time he knows me he's
based on my best friend but also the
best strength conditioning coach in the
world strength condition coach for the
Broncos now shout out to Lauren so he's
with me and he sinned and my my old
coach is trying to visualize things a
fight I'm a just off he's like I want
you I want you to go back to when you
fought Roy Nelson you remember that
moment and I'm like okay I'm like wah
I'm like where we going with this but
I'm like I'm a mama gonna guess I want
to remember what you felt like when he
[ __ ] hated that right there's your
first loss and I was like okay and I'm
like Gabby's like you're not feeling
like a a now I want you to take yourself
to Brazil all right and you fought did
you fight that he four guys that could
you fight they're all big Nagios bats
right so he fought the legend Nogueira
and you're in Brazil you flew 17 hours I
think remember remember that trip so
you're down there right and the locals
are nasty to you can you take all this
in I'm like mm-hmm you guys keep your
eyes closed I'm like yeah goes so
remember that biggest fight of your life
biggis fighting life we flew all the way
down there families that everybody made
sacrifices get down there so expensive
you didn't make much money and then
again another right hand do you remember
what that felt like I'm all in my head
I'm thinking like yeah he's like now
fast forward past that we're in Atlanta
you see and he can't remember yes
there's a ton of he it's not works he
goes there's a ton of them now so here
we are we're in Atlanta and fight Ben
Rothwell over 50 fights phenomenal
fighter remember that fight mall in my
hand like is he [ __ ] with me right
angles we tell you to take it because we
told you to take it easy dragging the
late rounds that's not your style so you
come out guns a-blazing through a
spinning backfist you wobbled him they
made a huge mistake and you got caught
with the left hand
openly wild wild do you remember that
and I'm like I literally open my eye
look at Lauren wounds like he's like now
once you take all that don't you bring
it to the cage of that he leaves and me
and Lauren can't stop laughing
I go Jim did he have like an earpiece in
from [ __ ] on the other team
what [ __ ] I go is that glad working
knocked aside left the one he wanted
your three worst fights your three
nightmare fights yeah well how can we go
over any of the wins
what what is it we had some big wins
lady come already the wind demon just
all to our losses another I want your
picture Brazil everyone made a ton of
sacrifices you didn't make much money I
was like oh wow I'll do thanks so I will
know I don't never get that angry about
it I will never I will never forget that
because me and Lauren Lana we we could
not stop what do you think of psych
coaches I think they're good if if
they're good they're there's a few of
them that yeah it's it's like stand up
yeah I think they're good they're good
if they're bad they're really bad they
can own between really if they're good
like I I have gotta get you out of your
way right that's just techniques that
you know you gotta you don't but these
techniques might help you along the way
maybe 1% you know but like I worked at
these Navy these
these guys who trained the Navy SEALs
and Special Forces team in the combat
yeah with like breathing techniques and
like fighter pilots yeah there were they
were great I still do it now to Stanford
stand up to wake me up
they would say good stuff yeah so what
what is the breathing technique that you
learned so people can hear about it yeah
it's a take forever and really yeah
that's all you got like how your breath
controls like so much combat breathing
they call it so much of what you do from
calming your nerves down to getting you
focused or waking you up like your
breath is so important so important yeah
yeah it's funny I was at somebody asked
me to talk about success you know and
I'm oh yeah I'm always very weary I hate
when people die but if they're young I'm
always really weird like I hate it
well because because it's very tricky
advice is very tricky and I would the
one thing I always say is the chances
are you already know everything you're
supposed to do you're just not do it
so then you can get read that quote
5,000 times yeah every Instagram oh yeah
that's right I can't stand right so like
it's all the but but I would say buy
what you love and go for it yeah but I
would say there are no playing time I
would say this but one of the things I
think that's important is that you if
you I think a lot of people have trouble
feeling like they deserve anything
that's a huge part of it yeah
but all the lis but that's you but
listen but some people just do for a lot
of reasons and it doesn't matter I think
what's helpful is if if that's the case
imagine who you'd like to be imagine
like a better version of yourself like a
perfect version or a better version and
then see what that person would like you
can do those kind there's certain
psychological tricks that help me you
know that can always choke in few you
didn't help you I'm more confused about
what else so you you can you can because
you can sort of imagine who you'd really
like to be right Wolverine all right and
then you ask yourself what do you what
is that person I need a lot of robotics
I need go through some painful
procedures there at nights in my hands
you want knives in your hands that's
what I want and you want to help me get
there right is this helping you a little
bit okay so let me let me back up and I
want to try to help you will be
Wolverine okay I hear you now I'm trying
to help you with your life can you can
you up to feel yeah oh you got to be
able to heal I know but can you cut me I
heal instantly I know you're making
a little bit difficult so all right let
me bat let me back just back up I'll be
spider-man how do I get there
well do you have a radioactive spider I
don't I'm trying to picturing okay
you're hating me your deaths paying me a
lot of money yes so these these I call
just so expenses are there any way you
could just not be so ambitious so can
you give me an idea of what the best
version of yourself is think about it
before you answer all right man yeah I'm
gonna is there any way you can not be a
superhero I really appreciate you I like
you know what [ __ ] that's [ __ ] some
grown man go Cinda Jimmy Burke and I'm
the Iron Man Jimmy Burke and I were so
close you know we'd always hang out and
Jerry McFadden was gettin mad he'd just
be like the [ __ ] guys he called he
called he got hey your bounces in town
your balance is he's not Jimmy would
have a foul he'd have a bounce to a step
when I'm in town love your bounce and
then final Jimmy's like yeah so Brian so
Juris listening Jimmy's like Brian Brian
and I were hanging out we're having so
much fun because hey hey hold on let me
ask you a question bro like if you had
to choose between Brian dying and your
mom hey who would you choose and Jesus
goes and there's a long pause then he
goes all right
you'd think you're overthinking it he
goes let me ask you again if you had to
choose between Brian dying or your mom
look at him that's a great shot of him
look at him he's the bottom of this
[ __ ] turtleneck always wear turtle
your dad man the greatest Jimmy burger
on Ravus I feel like we talked about
every pot just somehow and we bring him
up wait is that the real TV broke right
there um oh dude you know how you're
talking [ __ ] about Italians put wine in
their marinara sauce yeah but so many
emails I know because those people are
stupid hey you hey with your dumb emails
be moving north in the north with
[ __ ] maybe you want your stupid if
you put wine in your [ __ ] yeah there's a
lot of people saying that's what they do
my dad was not gas is not happy
don't go to any if you ever have to
divide your despair sauce I'm not going
but that's gonna [ __ ] you up me demands
that the wine you put in Tamara if you
put wine in tomato sauce you're not
Italian I said we've had some real
talent reach out chefs good chefs I
don't believe you oh wow
and I disagree oh wow take your boy
Stallone see what he says
see what he says dude dude huh last
night DeLeo show me picture of his baby
I know looks a little old man but you
you he was so I don't know what I don't
know I expect you know a lot of counts
don't talk about the kids or show their
kids he was so proud I know I was
getting emotional I was a kooky Jude I'm
so proud of him he said you know silly
wild dude he was every a teddy Whitney
like dude Lee this this might be the
first time smiling look at this and show
in the video long video to the Chris I
didn't wanna say anything last night cuz
you're really in the mood too long
though we all sat around for the videos
a minute long yeah yeah the other like
we gotta you gotta edit it so we just
see the kids smiling was way too long I
was at Sebastian's house for some big
thing that he had and Chris was there
Whitney was there and Chris he kind of
backs up and I follow him and he goes I
love my son so much yeah I was waiting
for the joke there was no joke oh he was
so proud man I was he's a newborn oh you
don't even know what I'm talking about
this stage just wait yeah that's a
football guys it's super mad all the
time just wait - he gets cute yeah I've
shown pics might get at three three
months like get the [ __ ] out of my face
exactly are we doing yeah I'm Wendell
DC's expat your kid I'm like [ __ ]
Gerber baby yes this thing's cute as
[ __ ]
and when he's six months it's gonna have
you seen my kids yeah the baby
yeah you should me photos did I it's
nuts yeah this one's you're stealing man
it's not he's cute as [ __ ] yeah I wanna
see little babies that some of them are
impossible do not have six kids I can't
get enough of yeah I can't get enough of
them they're so cute [ __ ] I know what
top some babies and gay I want I want to
move in with you in the top babies
good you play the mom part no yeah no
papa you know Papa makes the bread here
Oh
even in like this weird ecosystem Wow
papa
well what do I do stay at home and do
what I like the old like you know you're
the guy like no hen hey yeah kind of
really like you know you like make
[ __ ] trinkets I made you I made you do
like we have advice will I go to you no
can you live long life oh you know I
made you dinner
yeah all right dude where are you gonna
be home soon
yeah I did you know you gonna be home
and you just roll be that guy strong
line smelling like another woman yeah
you know me don't bend when I don't see
what thought I thought was me if you
know I'm dumping what I don't see I'm
always working on my ass to look at they
try to test a good look hell yeah keep
getting my face tighten yeah ha I'm so
happy to see you how was your trip I
gotta kiss you like this would be mean
gay guys ya mean gay guys you guys fight
dude they fight fight I heard that with
gay relationship I told you this final
guy was stabbed in the face 50 times
dad's on a ride-along yeah never do I
mean I'm you should do it cops hit us up
we should do a ride-along and it was at
the time I was in college I'm super
depressing but now because I watch so
much cop movies I would love that yeah
absolutely love it she goes they took me
and homegirl is about to commit suicide
well I'm too young to handle all that
yeah so they go when they try to talk
her out of it and then the guy comes
lucky like you know what we talked her
she seems alright I'm like you she leave
her in there little by itself yeah she
can't she has a cat like bald dudes I'm
really sure she died like the next day I
remember when I was in my apartment in
New York my parents have an apartment
across the hall i I just hear a
commotion and a bunch of dudes about
your size New York guys booost ashes
giant parrot like fireman fireman with
mustaches and all but as big as you add
and know and add the outfits I'll add
the boots and the you know just the all
the equipment and they knock on the door
and a oh and I'm not it's not funny but
she opens the door she goes hello
and he goes hi you okay and she goes
yeah anything goes it's deep
we was that you sitting on your
air-conditioner 16 floors up and she
goes um I guess what you on your
computer on your air conditioner and
then the air condition sticks out she
was sitting on top of it trying to
commit suicide and she goes she goes
yeah what I mean he goes do you think
that's normal and she goes yeah and he
said you think it's normal sit on your
air conditioner 16 floors that when she
goes like this yes oh and she went oh
and she collapsed and they grabbed her
and they they brought oh really no she
was good she was about to commit suicide
I bowled bad they saved her life though
they put her on a stretcher right in
front of me and they they calmed her
down she had up she was having an
episode and she was just I'd seen her I
would see her you know she was a single
young gal but these guys deal with that
real that's and I you know they have a
lot of [ __ ] lives I love passion
stuff my siepermann I wave out of me I
salute them yep everybody look does
anybody not like fire may save lives
hey give him another inspirational
quotes oh I got good mustaches broomy
service yeah I want to be a fireman that
can't carry that hose oh that's weak you
know like depression committing suicide
while we're on it I
Pete Davidson has a special on Netflix
come out right
which eye goes hard on Louie CK guys
it's pretty interesting yeah he legit
reason to I can tell you I'm not give
away the joke but he sat down with
Charlemagne who does these one-on-one
interviews they're fantastic it's on
YouTube and he was talking about Pete
Davidson by like you know he dates the
hottest chicks whatever he thinks the
hot chicks has a huge dick huge dick you
know that he's the originator of big
dick energy ariana grande started that
with Pete as a huge [ __ ] and he's on
Saturday Night Live and all that but he
suffers from horrible the horrible
depression dude awful depression don't
rally cuts himself in all Jesus Christ
yeah and how like Donna he's got those
giant bags under his eyes he's the
nicest guy though man I've met people
he's the nicest [ __ ] guy huh and
everybody hates are like I wonder why
why would you hate is it just gets a ton
of chicks is because he [ __ ] all these
really famous chicks I think that has
something to do with it and then I think
it's probably a group of people who love
art
grande but what would you think go kind
of crazy it might afford that probably
he without even trying makes news
and so people that's what I said and he
was like man I try he's like I swore me
a stand up new Senate lobbies like done
Sally live in I get what he's saying he
goes on Senate live he's like I just say
something to the writing room because
they always made me have to be that like
the dumb guy so in every bit I was the
dumb guy he's a cop see I'm not a dumb
person but they made it to be like this
he goes and I've gone on the road you
stand well nobody wants to pay to see a
dumbass like you no one's gonna pay to
see a dummy so it's actually hurting me
you decide to go in the writing room
like no I couldn't sell jay-z I can't be
the dumbass of every scene every now and
then fine but I can't just be the dummy
and everything yeah so you know he's
obviously he's having a hard time a lot
of times he doesn't he was a comedian
phenom dude he was like 17 yeah doing
legit stand-up and like the seller and
[ __ ] and then open for Chappelle and
just when he struggled it out when he is
I think yeah he's not Wilin out he he
talks about I've always liked him and
but he's super nice to me
I love Pete Davidson but talks about
yeah he has a bit out of it but it opens
up a special how when he was on Saturday
Night Live Lucy Kay was on that and you
know Pete Davis smokes a lot of weed cuz
instead of taking prescription
medications weed helps him calm down and
not be so crazy right so he's a big
advocate for weed so he was smoking weed
you know on the set you know that's way
does Lorne Michaels smokes weed but not
as much as him he was saying so he was
getting high and that's when Louie CK
was hosting so he says he gets off the
elevator and Louis CK's like holding
court with all the the cast members and
Pete just like waves and Lucy came for
him look how [ __ ] high that kid look
how high Pete Davidson like this [ __ ]
kid he was so goddamn high man smoking
his life away and Pete said he was so
heizak that didn't happen that's that's
not real that's in whatever it gets on
the elevator
next day he gets a call from Lorne
Michaels office he was which is weird
cuz I've been here for how many six
years he goes they've never once called
me so that I'll [ __ ] here we done we get
fired things didn't get fired every week
right
he goes up there in Laura Michaelis hey
once you know Lucy cake in my office
yesterday and asked me to fire you I let
you go and Loren Michaels like not
happening like you smoke weed but maybe
just don't do it as much in front of the
guest stuff like that but do your thing
it's what makes you you and so Peter
it's like what the [ __ ] man say he was
just a dick to all young comics he's
ever met Lucy Kate's been you know
what's going on he's gonna dick his
entire life so he's I'm not I'm like
anyway that's the premises this joke is
yours so then I wake up one morning
it's about Louie CK jackoff front of
women I should go yes he goes on this
bit but you know what if you talk to any
young comments that Louie CK is known
for that
yeah I'm not telling anything you don't
know special new you I'm not saying
there's a reason why a lot of people
like oh wow mmm-hmm well Louie from my
experience i don't know him Louie was
never a very warm guy that's one of the
issues was seemed very generous yeah
when that stuff came out that was one of
the issues is he was just an [ __ ] to
everybody that was one of the issues
yeah everyone's like a [ __ ] that yeah
LEM fry you know according to fire he
was not known in comedy circles for
exposing himself is not true
enforcing lesser-known communities to
watch him s it's not true that that's
this is when people start [ __ ] things
out with nobody it wasn't known it in
fact the I'm you say I've been in this
business a long time
Lulu seek a jacket off yeah there wasn't
really known that that wasn't until
things started coming out and then that
story came out that there was one story
I know the guy I died I know a lot about
it it did these these things get a
little crazy but but I will say that my
experience is you call it right away
that yeah yeah I think when you're an
older when you're an old economic and
you're established it's upon you to make
it easier on younger comics and be cool
hmm and be generous hmm and it means the
world to young comic it does and I both
I've seen a lot of comics through the
years who would go up and bump everybody
because they do two hours not these days
though is that everyone get away with
anymore either store if you tried that
you know if we're gonna bump why'd you
say like let's say someone came and
bought me like in about me I'm the new
guy right yeah they bought me I went to
you I was like hey dude blank
X comic but me you and rogue inner
whoever crit
whoever like they did what yeah well
that's not what we do around now yeah
and you say take me out of it because
I'm their friend but it is like me it
used to be like excuse me bump yeah I
never did that ever you know yeah I mean
yeah everyone's so nice like last night
I was sitting before I got my set and
Bobby comes up goes hey you know you
belong here yeah you know you belong
here no these jobs in my hand other than
that that's really cool good for Bobby
that [ __ ] um
he looked [ __ ] sweet to you took his
glasses off but he had these [ __ ] so
this sweet outfit on yeah okay he's got
a podcast with Santino now yeah they do
it's great I love it yeah I want to hear
it they uh look I put twins obviously
from the movie twins people that go but
that's racist cuz your agent no you
[ __ ] idiots are all sports a DeVito
my faith is so big you got a big smiling
listen you begin this young terrible you
you're terrible smiler
I'm terrible just smile smile that's a
smile don't do it like that
just smile normal with your eyes you
[ __ ] weirdo
I don't just smile easy oh man yeah
alright
no don't play your nose nope
keep your nose normal keeping those
quiet keep your nose quiet you know this
has to stay quiet nice I'm like you
better be hip oh yeah
it's my I don't know what to do I need
lessons I don't know and I just me
smiling dude I'm cheesing I don't know
what to do you ever get smiled cat oh
thanks I think it's also from the angles
is your know that I think it's the angle
because no one looks good from like a
lower angle and you're taller than
everyone you should take a photo with
true so it might just be angles I'm
Bobby looks great
you know wolfing bare hands if you had
to land a big timber wolf how big how
much you talk to how much way
bring up how much a big timber wolf wear
it Jesus like a Minnesota timber wolf
yeah there's a big animal I mean you got
to do it doesn't save you like Kevin
Garnett we're coming after your kids
now-now-now job comes out 51 to 120
pounds oh that's a huge animal oh my god
full ground Happy's a full-grown 180
pounds there so yeah they'd be tough I I
do think I could with my hands you could
what do you know what was happening last
night is I was hanging out with Talia
and Craig in those guys and a Navy
special force guy came up was a cob
what's up he's a little drunk he's like
shabwa
I came here for you man I could tell
right away I went special force he goes
how'd you know my it's like looking at
me like you used to fight they think
it's what you know but Dean lacrosse
just you know like they're dialed in
it just outed it the Hat you just the
pot if you watch it's just the whole
thing American sniper but you know yo
special agents how'd you knew how did
you know he starts talking and he walks
away and they all go in a fight you like
UFC fighters Navy SEALs I went I can
answer that question well I might well
just does it it's just different
I should we should train and this is not
just there's a ton of Navy SEALs could
whup my ass but no you're like jock
oneself would give me a lot of Fritz but
he's a black belt phenomenal black man
but why East we stood to have Navy SEALs
and certain Special Forces come train
Tim K monster they used to come I'm not
saying straightening I'm not saying
train canes them happens to be a fighter
also special right which is different
I'm starting just straight a Navy SEAL
special force guys used to train with
like Nate Marquardt los all the time
it's just different yeah it's just
different let a guys strong guys but you
get my gun a knife yeah they're
destroying us or a game plan they're
destroying all of us but when it comes
to the art of jiu-jitsu and fighting
it's a friend Carlos Condit and Michael
Bisping talk about it oh do they let's
combat so cross continent and Michael
Bisping went to I like to talk like cuz
I don't know I think you read so much
respect for news I bring it up you're
right it's like asking there was last
night and D'Elia and those guys like
dude if a fight happened with that Navy
SEAL knee what would happen like well
like asking how I would do if you hand
me a gun against him yeah how he would
do on stage yeah he's gonna [ __ ]
different things it's a different
language it's if he trained me but but
mentality wiser so Carlos Condit and
Michael Bisbee they don't tattoo yeah
I'm telling you they don't tell you
gotta know Muslim art can attack and
I've got a yeah yeah back to Gordon
Carla cause Connor and Michael Bisping
some of the other guys went to a fob a
Forward Operating Base with these elite
guys probably Delta guys I mean they all
had beards and they were all like there
and they were in the middle of a war
they were fighting the killing and every
guy was just [ __ ] tough as [ __ ] and
Carlos said well we'll move around they
were rolling with the guys and just kind
of light the sparring and then the guy
said to Carlos let's can we spar a
little you know I do some stand-up so
Carlos said all right I'm will just you
know they did not plans and it's Carlos
Compton because it cause like all right
so Carlos like puts on like his he
didn't he didn't have a ger but the guy
put a mouthpiece in if Karl's put a
mouthpiece in they were just gonna move
and Carlos stand there and the guy
punches him as hard as he can I don't
know where they're good knocks - Carlos
[ __ ] you knocks Carlos down
oh yeah what almost not horses baby
almost knocks him out and Carlos gets up
the guy's huge with a beard and Carlos
shakes his head he's like what the [ __ ]
I'm on and yeah and Michael goes this
he's fighting and Carlos goes okay oh is
that what you want to do bop bop Combe
head kick kick him out of the ring sir
kicked him out of the ring and knocked
in the [ __ ] out it's it's a different
thing you're not gonna be you can be a
Navy SEAL Delta Force and an absolute
badass and an athlete and everything
else you're not gonna beat Carlos Condit
in an MMA fight no it's just different
kind of dude then if you if you put if
you put 80 pounds of gear on his back
and a half shore hike six miles you're
not a [ __ ] sniper charlotte's and I
can do very well in Carlos probably
would if he trained but not like those
guys maybe not just different it's a
different thing it's a different body
type some of those guys are also like
you know they say a lot of Navy SEALs
don't make it a lot of really good
soldiers I've heard Navy SEALs say that
a lot of really good prospects who could
be great soldiers great opera
don't make it and you know what the what
the factor is for some people they just
can't handle the cold there are some
body types for whatever reason that just
go got they they hypo out they can't
conserve body heat I would be one of
those people I'm amazing in the heat I
cannot deal well I key dinkle yeah some
people can do it you know and they have
some great guys athletes big strong guys
and they just didn't hold breaks him
down there's one dude I know who's a
Navy SEAL he didn't make it through buds
he kept getting hypothermia and the the
drill sergeant stuck a thermometer in
his ass and taped it to his leg so that
they could monitor him cuz you know
you're standing in the cold they do
these crazy things and they would
monitor him to see what his body
temperature was I don't wait and fall
they put in the [ __ ] huh he didn't
pass he didn't pass because of emotional
things he got in a fight get competent
but he was that he was one of students
he can do a pull-up with one hand he'd
have to be news yeah but thin like big
strong but thin yeah and your body can't
take it there's so many factors like
that yeah you know then Tim Kennedy also
was talking about how the good operators
not always about who you kill it's about
knowing who to kill and who not to kill
that's a huge part of it you know
there's all these [ __ ] things that go
into it like anything else another guy
knows a ranger he said when he got on
the scale he's about 225 when he got on
the scale there's the other thing you
don't think about to jump out of the
plane
he weighed 400 pounds he had 175 pounds
worth of [ __ ] gear on radio
everything and sometimes that's so it's
you you run you shoot you're great now
I'm gonna put a hundred and twenty
pounds on your back you do that to me
and I'm not gonna I'm not taking you out
Deontay Wilder gonna fight after 40 40
40 if I put that you can do it you've
got like you can handle that no probs me
sir I've done yeah you've done that done
that yeah you'd have you'd have no
problem I mean where that weird suit
I've had 80 pounds I'm at the official
gear that the Marines have used not for
you but it says I dot the blood I've
done the whole their whole game I ran up
the mountain yeah you're you're a freak
that was fantastic
I love it well you would have been a you
couldn't do that you you're different
different kind of guy yeah I mean you
are but um but well how would that do
I saw that I mean is there is there do
you have is that legit to you is that
what is that I don't think so it's it's
it's more of a bummer and again I like
Deonte so I I don't want to post and
you're too hard at him right young he's
been really nice to me you know and you
respect him I love him
yeah I loved you up there water and his
family and his wife and the kids are
great you know when he posted ice went
okay I 20
okay yeah okay you know I'm not making
photos but that like all right yeah it's
a bummer do you do you see the second
fight going the exact same way or the
third fight you mean - I'm sorry third
fight yeah there's nothing you do to
beat Tyson curious you can't he can't
say I'm gonna start learning how to
fight on my manhood yeah $40,000 I know
outfit that's what saying 40 grand he
doesn't every every you know I love the
mask this was a little different I
always I always enjoy it it looks pretty
sweet
yeah thanks pretty sweet I had some
current events yeah now if you if you
you spent lot of time in bed all right a
lot of if you're a lovemaker if you're a
lovemaker and you're a sexual athlete
like myself and you like your sleep
dude were a couple sexual athletes
aren't we're a couple sex athletes now I
need a bed that's going to respond to my
my the contours of my body do you all
have different bodies when this when you
know when that when you're laying it
down yeah when you're laying that down
that that D game yeah you need some
Springs I need some spring some spring I
need some spring somebody saw that you
need to be daddy's little light yeah
that's how you get a DS little light
yeah that's how you get it that's how
you get a rhythm
that's why I'll take a two-minute quiz
yeah can't a match that matches my body
cuz I I get my mattresses helix you know
helixes they got some sleep I hit him up
I went I went through the I went through
the survey and there's nothing on their
set scale one to ten how hard you pound
well the he got it 10 now you might be a
side sleeper you might be a hot sleeper
you like a plush or embed with helix
yeah there's no confusion you know I
have to compromise on an average
mattress they were the helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2019 2020 by GQ and
let me say it again I tell you I can't
actually what about my house dude
people come on my house clap Hilux
mattresses yeah and all of a sudden I'm
basing around a bed-and-breakfast that's
right now they don't want to allow young
ladies to stay no no because because
what happens is goodnight it's just who
come the minute they hit the bounce dad
they get kicked out of that ten bounce
bounce there you go and and being a
sexual athlete like yourself which
sexual athletes
I need sex on earth and the pillows I'm
squeezing one right now do you gotta
keep literally as we speak they stay
cold they stay cold and there were a
couple hot head they're lovely for your
hot heads we need coal pellet I got a
hot head and not heavily I need a hot I
got I need a cold Paulo I need some some
springs in my mattress and I need helix
now $200 off all mattresses all right
that's right
three fellows for you guys so you HOT
heads and UK 10-year warranty all right
for a hundred nights risk-free what else
you want man I'll pick it you don't like
it helix sleep calm slash fighter for
$200 off that's helix sleep calm slash
fighter for $200 off all mattresses and
free pillows just try it for other
nights if you don't like it it's
risk-free they'll take it back just go
to helix sleep calm slash fighter take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress just
for you for the best sleep of yo life
good night sweet prince
hey B I just announced I'm headed to
Austin I'm head loss in March 19th
through the 21st cap City baby he'll be
at the app city partners they set out
that thick bat-signal yeah a thick whole
bat-signal said hey somebody fell out
we need this thick bat-signal ooh some
tickets I said I'm coming but only if I
can go to on it is it come on down bro
you're gonna be down there and I know
what you're gonna do you're gonna go
ahead and get yourself one on shakes
with all that awesome Pompey shake it up
proud of its week I'll be shaking it up
dude got the Alpha bring they throw in
there maybe throw in some I don't know
shroom tech support yeah do nothing like
working out with those with that on it
program those honored kettlebells and
all that on of equipment and then
getting on it when you have that that
wonderful shake
and it's just booty central and I can't
wait Frank Oh Jim oh man I'll do that
the sweatshop are you the 30 minute pump
forget it pump but after we're done sled
throwing a ball whatever functional
fitness ah and then you can save temps
laughs go to audit comm slash fried four
attempts enough MCT oh the almond one
with my face on it's fantastic then he
got freaking protein bars they got funny
workout videos they got on it on demand
you can do it from your hotel whatever
you want and they got my favorite coffee
it's the [ __ ] yeah coffee it's highly
highly caffeinated coffee black rifle on
it one clap get it now on it calms last
fighter 10% off it's just such a bad
like look I would yeah it's just such a
bad look out of all the reasons into
it's just such a bad look yeah okay so
on Monday while we were filming the show
in downtown LA there was a memorial held
in Staples Center for Kobe and a bunch
of his friends and family members went
up and gave a speech and his wife gave a
eulogy for Kobe and their daughter do
you see any of this I didn't see it this
part I saw it I haven't seen this I saw
clips I couldn't watch it it's just this
is it yeah I want my daughters know and
remember the amazing person husband and
father he was
I can't machine get up there time no it
was amazing she seems to be better and
keep them from making his own mistakes
he always liked working and doing
projects to improve kids lives he taught
us all valuable lessons about life and
sports through his NBA career his books
show detail and his puny x' podcast
series and we're so thankful he loved
those lessons and stories your friends
Lakers he was thoughtful and wrote the
best love letters and cards and Gigi had
his wonderful ability to express her
feelings and to pake paper and make you
feel her love through her words she was
thoughtful like him
they were so easy to love everyone
naturally gravitated
towards them they were funny happy silly
and they loved life they were so full of
joy and adventure
God knew they couldn't be on this earth
without each other he had to bring them
home to have them together pain you take
care of our chichi and I got nani BB and
Coco we're still the best team and
[Applause]
unconsolable grief that's what they call
me as they get Michael Jordan actually
ended up going up and making a speech as
well this was kinda I saw his it's funny
Judah he's the crying mean yeah yeah my
wife when do say another [ __ ] four
years they pray I'm surprised he cried I
just ordered yeah just just to make that
speech because we were so close I didn't
know that I did not know that they were
so close you don't realize how close
Kobe was with it yeah everybody looked
it to be at his level and you're talking
like there's a story they said he wants
you know because his daughter was on a
traveling basketball team and they went
and played in Canada and the facilities
in like the uniforms weren't good and
the dad was the cow were trying to
figure out Kobe would text him every
week
dami people he has to nabi say takes him
every weekend check in on understand him
dad that he met because his daughter
played in the same league in canada one
game and the facilities weren't good and
he's trying to grow women's basketball
he takes him every week they say it
takes hundreds of people yeah every week
check in with them you're Kobe Bryant
they don't sing that it what a monster
do uh-huh
what he [ __ ] insolence excellence
personified in every sense of the word
excellence beast of a Papa - I thought
it was so interesting when Michael
Jordan was saying how he called him in
the morning I was like I mean two or
three in the morning asking him
questions
were hard to watch man it's hard hard
what okay so there is a video taken last
weekend where Hilary Duff confronts a
photographer who people are assuming is
a paparazzi trying to take photos of her
and her kids while they're at a soccer
game she confronts him asking are you
here with anyone do you know any of
these kids or families he says no and he
says that he's practicing his
photography and that it isn't illegal
for him to be there and take photos and
she just tells him can you please just
human a human not take photos of our
kids since you're not here with anybody
it's very creepy what do you say and he
says it's not illegal man what a piece
of [ __ ] and she posts it I don't know
what the laws what a piece of [ __ ] so
you're taking pictures of children I'm
already quit sorry too creepy and it's
not your children you just randomly
going to the soccer game taking pictures
of kids yeah you got you do that to my
kids and there's my punches yeah its
rear I'm violin but that'd be the one
time where you'd see me on the news like
Oh former MMA comedian beat the [ __ ] out
dude taking pictures kids yeah was this
guy now that's a different occasion
where Hilary Duff went and she saw a car
following her all day and she stopped
and realized it was a paparazzi trying
to get a photo of her just throughout
her weekend and she asks him hey like
can you do this on a weekday this is my
weekend can I just live you know it's
crazy to me is have you ever seen it
when like Hilary Duff anybody JLo the
post a picture of that somebody took of
them and they all sue them even though
it's them and their likeness yeah
they sue the photographer Susan gets
money out of them that happens a lot the
world dude it's just so just these
scumbags like where were your parents
all the problem we were your parents
myself was a cake dad yeah my job is
that I fought really famous successful
people and I invade their privacy and I
snap hidden pictures and I try to catch
them doing terrible things it's not
legal
it actually ain't legal like the man
claimed at least Cora Calvin or was
appear to have happened wow you can't
take pictures Governor Brown signed the
SB 606 into law which made the
photographing of minors because of a
parent's employment illegal if it fails
in Falls in the area of harassment
annoyance alarm or torment without
legitimate purpose punishable by up to
one year in jail good hard stay at this
particular incident meets the criteria
spelled out in the California at all but
you you've got to imagine a Hillary
might want to have that little factoid
in their back pocket for next time glad
I have it in my back pocket for the next
time a couple of years ago there was
this big movement where a bunch of
celebrities stopped like buying and then
showing it showing up for magazine
covers with magazines that'll buy photos
from paparazzi all around this Weekly
with their kids yeah that's crazy how is
that okay how is that insane I don't
know that's why a lot of well no not
like it's bad certain areas but I don't
know what else y'all God has that ever
happened to you guys with your kids
thank God thank God huh okay so a couple
in Florida went to a Dunkin Donuts
drive-thru they grabbed their doughnuts
they started eating and midway through
the wife who is driving realize that
there was blood on the bag damn and on
the napkins oh you mother like cut his
hand on accident you know yeah that's
what she thought initially oh are one of
us bleeding yeah she they made sure that
neither of them were bleeding they
actually went back to the same
drive-thru the woman who handed heard
the doughnuts actually had a napkin
wrapped around her hand that was bloody
uma and it turned out that she got a
paper cut and didn't know until
afterwards she was trying to cover it up
but this is just a video he bludgeons
bullets ah yes
all-natural doughnut that's what she was
saying but that's a problem but a
vicious on the bag but if it's on the
bag I'm gonna assume it's gonna be on
the doughnuts I was that way a lot of
people are saying cuz the the girl who
is working trying to offer them free
doughnuts the said no and yeah they said
no they end up going
the hospital like I have a lawyer
oh no use a $25 gift card all the [ __ ]
you don't offer not even that Dunkin
Donuts also offered to pay for all of
their tests and anything oh yeah okay
I'll get about 10 grand
you can you imagine today if you call me
like hey what's up dude dude listen to
this it's just freeze it was that might
was that the drive-through if Dunkin
Donuts blood all over the bag right so
listen what I'm gonna do I'm going to
the hospital now you test it can sunos
and then we're gonna sue Dunkin Donuts
I'm like hey dude don't come in Monday
scuse me
we don't do a show anymore together yeah
I don't have any people associate would
do that yeah it's it the problem is it's
it's what they says it's talking about
it's a free it's know they think in
their mind they go we didn't get
$100,000 and what happens the reality my
buddy's a lawyer right my one buddy bit
into a piece of chicken from Trader
Joe's and it had glass in it when he
broke his [ __ ] tooth so he was like
what the hell and it turns out they'd
had another incident like this maybe it
wasn't Trader Joe's it was something
like that so he talked to my buddy who's
a lawyer he said my tooth is [ __ ]
broken I mean like that's not right yeah
and he goes and it's glass the problem
and my buddy goes yeah you guys you
think he goes I mean I don't know what
do you think is it worth going through
this you know because he's not like that
and my buddy goes a lot of people in
this situation think they're gonna make
a hotter gram let me tell you what's
gonna happen you're gonna get you'll
make about $9,000 boy fees everything
you just make about 9 grand you know
it's one person buy like some drink and
there's like a straight-up rat in it
like obviously just through the
distribution the rapper I just jumped in
the [ __ ] bottle wait why it was a
coca-cola thing yeah and then some
person they think is plant though it
felt like a human oh it wasn't yeah like
a thumb or a taco bell's like that's now
how would you like yeah if it wasn't
planned like if I got like you know some
[ __ ] McNuggets and there's somebody's
like finger in it that's what I'd like
wow I can't eat this man lies dead rat
and Red Bull can't after he took 7,000
now that's got to be worth some money
wait thought he's gotta be worth some
money a dead ringer to save his lip Oh
major problem at yeah yeah that'd be an
issue it is lip this just wrapped if I
could have put if I could have put her
right in there dude my breath have you
seen this video oh [ __ ]
have you seen that video that pig
running oh yeah the javelina well it's a
javelina it's like it's the same family
bring it up dude Jason to me onstage in
another station no Jay sends me this
video goes can't get enough this pig I'm
like what the [ __ ] I clicked that this
[ __ ] pig is what woke in it yeah they
call doing work baby think it's thick
see amazing ly fast huh it's thick
seasoned dude he's up in the Arizona
dude look at him that's a badass house
it's like a koala bear
Hakuna Matata man that's a hot on you
net Halloween the things God move in
Arizona what the [ __ ] is a javelina it's
to say that's like the same thing is a
real wow that's a that's a [ __ ] that
board board all he's got is running he's
got to run away from mountain lions and
[ __ ] and humans yeah
hedgehogs can run to this office better
quality not hedgehogs I mean warthogs
obesity not fast look at him get his
little he's a little [ __ ] a flexible
little guy all this time he's Charlie -
did you know bu I can't get enough for
me that he's [ __ ] I would say would have
fallen for hours
where's he go how long for you to run
for it what a stud what else you got oh
well the Harvey Weinstein thing you're
right
so high-ranking officials at New York
City's Department of Corrections is
telling TMZ that they're worried that he
might actually hang himself like
Einstein oh sure I call potentially
hang himself or something had the hook
died in the Beco he died of [ __ ] you
know pneumonia but really this is gonna
offer me it's too much info about what
done Hollywood celebrities who also
[ __ ] with girls your bet he dies next
month I'm back the net is my leaving
that kill himself but nah you complained
of chest pains and stuff right when he
got right after the verdict and then
into the hospital then he hired a
like like they get hard movie with Kevin
Hart and Will Ferrell where he's going
to prison
Will Ferrell hires Kevin Hart to get
ready for prison he legit hired a guy to
get ready for prison like what to expect
yeah you mention that it's been like
this is my life dude well he never
thought he'd this it would end this way
I mean this is crazy
yeah how was he gonna do how much time
to Reno
it said five - top five five yeah they
said a probably on also probation Oh
about two still what a lot of money two
years you need tears and just kind of go
away he's still partying when he was out
you know after all that Stan had pearls
everywhere so Justin and [ __ ] girl
that's a lot of disgusting nut yeah yeah
what else you got
his wife is dating Adrien Brody I know
that just came out today I think right
what his ex-wife she's hot the one that
left him after all the stuff came out
she Asian she like oh oh that's less
musi what she looks like she's all
worried I'm piece oh [ __ ] she's a she's
a designer clothing designer question
disguise him I know she's gorgeous
married for what images for me dude
all right let's have a look-see what did
she upgrade yeah
there's no way though he's inviting him
to a cocaine party though the nose out
Jesus Christ
he fell off for a little bit right yeah
what do you think it is big noses went
out for a while no dude she is delicious
that's his wife he is disgusting just
take a look look at him and then look at
her it just doesn't look like what's
going on it looks like an ogre in a
fairy look and he really constantly just
Shrek and that's Fiona when she was Cara
Gosselin cheating on it look at that I
mean what though Wow got a question her
though well she's mentally no she was in
she was ambitious he looked the finest a
lot of her [ __ ] I think clothing did
she give me any movies no she was as
she's a clothing designer she she was a
successful designer well he's just
seeing her he gave her money she is
painful she she had a lot of celebrities
wore her clothing she's
gorgeous look at him oh yeah but here's
the thing I'm women are into that no
girl I don't know dude like here's the
thing yeah yeah he funded your clothing
paying you paint at night you're paying
gonna cycle up to that thing probably
wasn't even out of sex with her yes
prime sex you know all the other girls
Oh magic kissing that [ __ ] monster
he's called his lips and she said you
did you read the deposition where she
said his vagina
I mean he's balls compared to not have a
penis he looked like he had any and he
smelled like poop and he had blackheads
on his back well that's also a lady
trying to the shame of too well no
Charlie no here is it so so so if she
isn't lying about that Brennan it would
have been he would have said she never
saw an asian chick no she would never
saw me naked if she was describing what
his dick didn't look like he could say
check this out really that's what
happened the Michael Jackson thing right
very smart on his dick she had a very
specific about what it looked like very
specific so you know and it had to be
accurate because she was in a court of
law and they could use doing her eyes
yeah so so he's got this guy that's got
it well he looks like that annie has no
dick that's a tough one
with no balls so enjoy that what a piece
of [ __ ] yeah
he's a bad guy that's a piece that's a
really bad
agent if I'm Adrien Brody I'm like
they're like dude are you kidding me
yeah I always slept with that they're
nothing busted not to you talk about
that guy either that poker was popping
[ __ ] pimples all over you
they got disgusting is yeah apparently
our Harvey Weinstein was none too happy
about that
how could she do this to me are you
serious Harvey hmm look at him look at
you dude she is fantastic she's so good
luck agent Brody man there's something
wrong with agent Brody his nose is a
little off you know me my ears leaving
are you personality I like is he a bad
person or mine disappeared what happened
be like you because you use in using
King Kong fantastic movie he was in the
pianist mm-hmm yeah and then he was also
and what and then and they just
disappeared
yeah I don't know what happened I don't
know I don't think it was because he's a
jerk I don't think I think I think maybe
he don't know yet
three Bob get three strikes in Hollywood
then they kick you out times that
there's that peaky blinders goes in that
yeah keep going he I think he had a
production company I don't know what
he's telling with it but Houdini's the
grand Budapest hotel oh that was a big
one yeah you don't like money that was
hard to you predators oh yeah he was a
predator the remakes Hollywood The
Pianist that was this big well that was
a big one won an Oscar he did win an
Oscar and then what happened he just
dipped out he's a good actor I remember
seeing him and I think the Spike Lee's
the mom I love them I always liked him
his nose was always so distracting yeah
he's always he was Tamara seeing him the
first time in a movie I think was a
spike Lee movie and I remember going
that guy's a really good actor there's
something about my teeth he stood out he
was just really good - nice nice hooking
up dunker your grow your beard like that
now he's hooking up with uh yeah Ari
Weinstein miss with miss Weinstein my
friend um kind of worked with him a
little bit and said he was really nice
so I'd okay yeah it's just weird right
he just went in my a for a little bit
now he's back mr. steel your wine thing
what else you got
uh Maria Sharapova I'm retired
30-32 passed away such a badass 32 how
young yeah ahead of her
yeah whole life and that's the honey in
the band for yeah a lot of money so I'm
gonna play should we all play masters
divisions and Oxford this they do
corporate things yeah and they make you
know but she I need it right and she has
filled all those sponsors
didn't she get busted for hate to be yes
she did no but it was it was a weird it
wasn't it was our it was Russian pee no
no it was a it was a thing that allows
it's like doping but what everybody was
taking it everybody and then that way
it's melih
melodium yeah hmm which wasn't which it
is no it doesn't build muscle it just
keeps you I guess it helps your
endurance
such as everything but air apparently
everybody was taking it and then yeah
they're always so talented who gives a
[ __ ] it's also Stennis so take all the
roids you want to give the flying Rock
you're hitting the ball not hitting
people right so I would take off you
know and all you want girl Angela
whatever you need her to stay whatever
makes it more exciting well you don't
smarty whatever it helps these white
girls compete with the Serena sisters
you know they beat does when she beat
Serena that was that she got on on the
on the map she was they went and Serena
was like well she's six feet tall six
one she's six foot one she's really big
and I'd see how tall she is she might
even be taller than that she's very tall
gonna 6-1 that's a huge huge gal six six
one I think that's a huge [ __ ] 62 very
nice very tall a giant gal and Serena's
nuts Venus as well Serena's successes is
Serena's not realize ten I would say way
shorter I'd say five sit next to her so
I didn't just Serena Williams for me
green areas not short dude it's not sure
but here there this picture see her
where she ever just get a nice dramatic
go down there I've been just type in
Serena willing I know but Bryan wants to
see something yeah just do that I think
go to all and then go time nine five
nine five nine yeah let's say five
that's that's a stretch to be absolutely
it's a stretch no I don't think so
I've been around I stood next to her for
about an hour I mean I personalized
thousand I was in her locker room I day
Miami oh I did it or not to upstage you
don't that different
she's such a beast killer it was better
ass go even close some some of these
tennis players you see some of these
tennis players they're so hot now oh my
god like take a look at something like
hot gal tennis players your favorite
keep Sampras no there girls you haven't
heard of but they like knock your dick
into the dirt think oh dude dude I feel
like punching you write you a hot text
once I like Anna Kournikova is the
biggest rather you would be you lose
your
[ __ ] stone oh yeah no say still no
you know no [ __ ] keep going chin no yeah
it was going on there that looks like a
kid yeah I don't know these are just
Instagram models with tennis rackets no
they're not they're high-level tennis
player yeah
don't talk right now ya know this you
know tennis he's offline oh wait hold on
let me see her
are you [ __ ] joking must be hard to
play with those big tits well for you or
to play tennis I know what that would be
hard for me to play with those big tits
don't you mean don't you twisted someone
a Halep you [ __ ] joking bring up
Simona Halep there she is there she is
there's some more our broker you know
how hot Anna Kournikova was though yeah
and then Ricky is not working is it Rick
inglesias
Enrique Enrique bus and nuts in a bunch
of kids who did enrique inglesias and
Antico know their stuff together right
yeah yeah yeah get off these now oh yeah
check out the arms on Becky what else
you got so this year an ESPN Cleveland
radio host called Baker Mayfield a
effing he's like the voice for clearing
Browns and a lot of people I've disliked
him for a long time and then this was
like the final hump he thought the mics
were off he's like you know we passed up
by the names all these great oh you got
there
whence Watson keep it going the home the
homes and now Bert and now burrow what
else we got suspended
oh my god no indefinitely so they might
even fire why cuz this is derogatory
turned towards little people get the
[ __ ] out of here guys talk it another
micron that's in by the way but hey
another micron I know I can just talk it
I'm sorry for my language now [ __ ] off
and the very bottom he says I apologize
to little people
all right did the guy sure he's been
doing radio forever and he's probably
really good a lot of people had issues
with him I mean I don't think should be
fired to calm you know get suspended or
something but not I'm not fired I mean
hopefully it's just a suspension I mean
I don't know give me yeah did you ever
see that commentator he lost his job
rightfully so college football as the
black guy run the ball you look at that
monkey go oh that was always a shame
about that
shall we go just a you know how's it
going
Jesus Christ yeah I know lost giant
think that would be weird like you know
it's just I don't know it cook yeah that
was a long time ago too though yeah not
to scare you guys but the CDC said that
it's not a matter of if it's gonna
happen is when it's gonna happen
the corona virus spreading here here's
the thing here's the thing eighty
percent of people yet coronavirus are
just fine
it's just like an SEM eighty percent
eighty percent yep makes me feel a lot
better now yes John yeah why why there's
some become pneumonia and people are
very few died two percent die thank you
what yeah it's weird it's like two
percent I shouldn't ever said have
severe symptoms eighty percent of people
have common cold symptoms its corona
virus and they move on thank you
this is all distraction yep hmm
and that was on NBC Nightly News by the
way by the way uh forget his name but
he's fantastic he's so serious
that's good to hear them yeah don't
worry about it okay go looking for it
but I'm sure it's like not canceling
canceling my Europe tour my brother
really roasted me instead
me those facts as well doesn't man I'm
I'm worried when I'm your attempt
breakout thing is what they sent me all
these fast alright I'll see you soon you
this was just fine because one of the
head members of the IOC his name is dick
pound and he's the one that said that
the Olympics could be possibly cancelled
in Tokyo because of the chronovisor
they're gonna give it like two three
must have figured out but then I knew
his they have real bad issues out there
though but then it says that they're
planning to go ahead with it a lot of
[ __ ] stick pounds I think it over it a
lot of condoms or not I played it safe
you feel about your body kill anything
you don't get to Olympics by playing it
safe that's right buddy do some [ __ ]
check this out Iran's deputy health
minister he has a corona virus and he
was doing a speech hopefully I have this
video read he looked like me during
podcast he's sweating now yes this is
him on a talk show
I know this is before he's coughing
there he looks like a fee on there
saying he has that I wouldn't trip yeah
well just look at him here he's just
suffering this is before he got
diagnosed
so he's like passing this around
everyone yeah get affect the common cold
though to be honest looking on it that
who gives a [ __ ] it's really not that
big of a deal it looks terrible
he's what I know he looks terrible he's
sweating cuz he's a serious cold man
yeah so he did test positive for nuance
can you bring up that LSD yeah all right
so this woman was at her friend's house
found what she thought was cocaine
snorted a lot of it and it ended up
being LSD she so RT yeah so it's about
550 times the normal dose that people
take and then apparently cured her Lyme
disease so she was getting pain from
mine disease she didn't have the
Punisher after that a lot of up in a
month can be in the mind to yeah they
haven't really they haven't a lot of
it's still controversy I have Lyme
disease isn't had it for a long time
they they don't really know she
scientists so my golden we don't really
have any old to be taking all these
[ __ ] drugs but yeah 46
and also she just snorted a bunch of
[ __ ] that was on the ground that's
called a drug addict because she was
like I don't all do it she's definitely
doing stuff I'll just you know she looks
like no party girl I know guys snoring
party mama saw cocaine and then there
was salt and he snorted the salt and he
goes this is weird so some people just
snort whatever we call data table yeah
so you know all right you know there's a
trend now on tick-tock the skull breaker
challenged which is terrible and kids
are doing it we're to ultra tick tock
aren't we I'll show you this borderline
too old for takeoff really yeah it's
young it's young but a lot of people are
getting on it like older ones that are
feel natural it's like when your dad
starts I feel like I'd be willing to do
that what if I got if I joined I
actually have the app but I won't and
enjoying it near you just in case man
you know to be in the know and watch
tik-tok so I think is it brother right
take that yeah so look how terrible this
is this is a so - people will plan it
with their third friend and the third
friends in the middle and they'll do
something to them so a lot of kids are
getting hurt and getting brain injuries
obviously from this hold on the goal is
to have the kid bash his head on the
ground well to fall down for sure wait I
don't know if they've met for his head
to be bad I don't think the goal is to
have your head smash on the floor I
think that's just a byproduct of taking
someone's legs out from under them what
it is called me freaking challenge so
might be that same [ __ ] [ __ ] that babe
yeah I don't want to show you the other
kid but that's a that's a she no
challenge you know this kids in the
hospital for it and usually I'm guessing
it has to be the bullies you know I'm
under you and you fall down don't do you
like worst-case scenario one kid stuck a
pencil icetown on it and it almost went
into my foot hurts Joe Valley it means
my rifle in my tank see that's funny oh
now that's funny
it was horrible so much pain that well
fish went out in college so that you'd
like keep people in the nut I never
liked that
oh I never enjoyed that why would you
like a stupid [ __ ] man
yeah who's Barbara Corcoran if you ever
watch that show shark tank so she's
pretty well-known she looks like you in
20 years
okay he's got a strong face strong face
don't you like writing a little bit like
when you're older yeah anyway it's her
team accidentally gave someone in
Germany $380,000 because if there was
like a little thing missing on the email
they thought it was you know part of
their team and they're asking for the
money like everything turned out to be
legit except for that one letter missing
on the email address and they actually
scanned them out of $380,000 for me hmm
Wow
yeah Jesus Christ that's impressive
it is right and I think that's it Wow a
bunch of [ __ ] idiots doing [ __ ] I'm
going to [ __ ] City
no Omaha Nebraska this weekend were sold
out completely sorry everybody sorry mom
not doing a third show on this Saturday
can't do it I just you do that you do
that still I don't know I do on Tara
want to I didn't do it can't do it I
can't do it Kansas City April 3rd and
4th so April's a busy month for me
Charlotte I got Charlotte North Carolina
I got a bunch of stuff what do you got
buddy a for a long time oh man um in
Tacoma this weekend Friday early show
Saturday sold out so you can get late
tickets Friday and I have one show
Thursday takes know available for that
Tacoma Washington this Thursday Friday
Saturday and then oh we just added two J
added I'm a slap his [ __ ] face oh we
did we just added Austin Texas March
19th through the 21st cats Austin Texas
cap cities March 1920 first I know I
love that place Austin Texas get your
tickets but before that theater tour
Atlanta March 13th New Orleans March
14th now I'm in Austin 19 through 21
Toronto March 26 Detroit March 27th
Minneapolis March 28 and then I'm off to
[ __ ] Europe all right dude tik-tok on
for tickets we got a bunch of Newmar
merch dropping soon and this [ __ ] is so
drippy
wait DC the new [ __ ] we got dropping
buddy really tea fat gay excited I can't
wait
I dude
this the fighter kid ran out